lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
hacer un par de aclaraciones con
respecto al vídeo anterior sobre
sanciona el matrimonio la primera
aclaración es que cometió un error
matemático al estar calculando este
tabulador del incremento de 17.850 a 72
mil 500 a que se le aplicará un impuesto
del 15 por ciento en lugar de tener
estos 8 mil 188 debe ser 8 mil 198 por
lo que al tomar esta cantidad en los
cálculos que hicimos este resultado debe
tener 10 dólares más en lugar de ser 43
mil 456 debe ser 43 mil 466 pero esto no
afecta la lógica seguida para encontrar
esos valores y son 10 dólares es muy
poquito dinero en el contexto de las
cantidades que estamos manejando aquí la
segunda aclaración que quiero hacer que
es algo más importante note que en los
comentarios en el vídeo anterior varias
personas sugerían que ya que costaba más
el impuesto que declaró un matrimonio
conjuntamente entonces que declararán
demanda
individual para evitarse esta sanción de
manera que cada integrante de la pareja
hiciera su declaración individual y así
sólo pagarían esos impuestos de acá sin
embargo lo que yo quiero aclarar es que
esto no es opcional si ustedes están
casados no se puede usar el tabulador
individual puro en cambio si ustedes
están casados pero quieren hacer su
declaración individual van a tener que
usar este tabulador de acá el tabulador
de matrimonio con declaración individual
o por separado como ven este tabulador
es exactamente igual a este tabulador
individual al menos en estos primeros
tres tabulador es cuando llegamos al
cuarto tabulador vemos que aumenta más
rápidamente que en el tabulador
individual solito y esto es porque si se
fijan en los valores de sus tabuladores
son exactamente la mitad de estos
tabulador es de acá el del matrimonio
con declaración conjunta y lo que hace
que para esta pareja de aquí que tienen
ingresos idénticos tendrán que pagar
exactamente la misma cantidad tomando en
cuenta nuestro error de redondeo para el
matrimonio con declara
separadas podemos hacer el ejercicio
sacamos nuestra calculadora cada uno
tiene un ingreso de 100 mil dólares al
menos en este ejemplo de la pareja
durante los primeros 8 1925 pagarán el
10 por ciento que es 893
incluso puedes usar la cantidad exacta
892 puntos 5-9 problemas en el siguiente
tabulador pagarán el 15% y a esto le
agregamos 4 mil 99 dólares
y en ese tercer tabulador se tendrá el
25 por ciento que es 9.238 que creo que
redondea este número y vamos a tomar en
cuenta este error por redondeo
y finalmente se pagará el 28 por ciento
del incremento por encima de 73 mil 200
así que cada uno gana 100 mil
a esto le quitamos 73.200
y esto nos da que cada uno tiene que
pagar 21 mil 733 puntos 5 dólares de
impuestos si esto lo multiplicamos por 2
no será 43 mil 467 así que esto nos da
aproximadamente 43 mil 467 que si lo
comparamos con esta cantidad pues es
casi lo mismo y recordamos que ésta fue
usando los tabuladores de la declaración
conjunta de matrimonio la diferencia se
debe básicamente a los redondeos que
dice aquí pero como podemos ver son
impuestos equivalentes así que para
aclarar si ustedes están casados tienen
que usar este tabulador de declaración
conjunta o si lo quieren hacer por
separado ese tabulador de declaración
por separado pero también que
corresponde al matrimonio pero no se
tiene la opción de hacer la declaración
como un individuo así que no podemos
evitar esa sanción al matrimonio si es
que ustedes se encuentran en este
escenario que acabamos de analizar